質問など 今日は今年最後ですので
思い出を残しておきたい
質問されたらいい 挙手されて質問してください
何かございませんか？ すいません
シム両身でですね シム両身
私はそのツーペアだと思うんですけど
その自と他と非と非っていうのがツーペアになってると思うんですけど
その生命の陽が当たってる部分を見て喜ぶと
その日陰になってる部分を見て憐れむ
そのカルマ非っていうのがあると思うんですけど
その生命が 四界の天にしても
その生きることは そのその喜びの要素とかを取り入れないと生きていけないので
すごいあの苦しいということになると
その 無量の心ということだと
その非の方が広げられると思うんですけど
それは違います  よくわからないですね
その生命の喜ぶというか
そのムディタはそのいい面を見ているわけじゃないですか
そのいい面というのは実際はほとんどなくて
苦しみの面の方が多いんで
そうするとその苦しみの方にスポットライトを当てて憐れむ心の方が無量の心というのも広がるんじゃないかなと
うんうん まあそれはその個人の思考で
まあそれは私たちにはどうも言えませんですけど
お釈迦様はみんなもうムディタを置いておいて
非だけ実践しなさいとは言ってないんだから
私にはもうそれには結論は言うことはできないんです
お釈迦様だったら慈悲喜捨ってもう適当に頑張ってくださいっていうことで終わってます
慈悲喜捨のそのどれがどっちが上だとか
そういうのはない  それはないんです
自分に当てはめるものを実践すればいいんです
そこは人のね 知恵の程度もありますから
だから最初は知恵があるということはしないんだからね
人にはね 知恵がない人が仏教を学び始めるしね
だからそれで学んでいくと
知恵がどんどん成長していく
知恵が成長していくと
自分のスポットライトがどんどん広げて広げていくんですね
で 知恵がない人には仏教を初めて聞いちゃうと
1点にしか当たらないスポットライトかもしれませんよ
知恵が出てくると このライトがどんどん広げていって
全生命にも当てはまるぐらいは広げる可能性はあります
それは知恵 知恵どこまで広げるかということなんですね
だから最初は慈悲喜捨の中でわかることで始めてね
いけばいいんです なぜそういうことを言ったかというと
この非の実践というのは
大体お釈迦様につける形容詞の一つなんですよ
偉大なる無量の憐れみを持つならば
もうそれはブッダであると
ブッダが輪廻脱出しているんだから
輪廻の生命を見るとみんな苦しんでいることで助けなくちゃということで義務が創立するんですよ
輪廻の中にごちゃごちゃやってること人ににとってはそういうふうに義務が生じないんです
だから我々はもう生命に慈しみを育てなくちゃいけないんだから
自分たちにピンとくるものを何か選んでやるんです
パーリ語の慈悲の言葉でアヴェーラーホントゥとかアヴェアパンジャとかニーガとかって言いますよね
日本語で訳を見ると 恨みがない者であるとか
怒りがないようにとか
惑混乱することがないようにとかっていう訳がされるんですけど
それってなんか慈悲喜捨っていう考え方でいうと
先ほど渡辺さんがおっしゃったみたいに
慈悲のカルマのような感じがするんですけど
でもなんか瞑想の名前がメッタバーナーって形で出てるんで
その辺はどう考えたらいいのかな
それは私の研究 これは私の個人的な研究だからね
まあどうでも嫌だったら捨ててもいいんで
私は注釈書やらね いろいろ調べると
みんな慈悲喜捨は良いことやと思う
断言的に決めてますけど
実際実践する場合はプラクティスどうすればいいかっていうことはそれほど研究されてないみたいです
もう何でも適当な言葉でいいんだから選んで唱えよと
だからもういっぱいありいっぱいありますよ
それで語呂がいいかとかね
唱えやすいとかね それは言語的にもありますよ
例えばパーリ語ではアヴェロー
アハンアヴェロー歌ってますからね
みんな そこはそのまま日本訳して歌えるかというと
ちょっと歌いにくいんですね
日本訳しちゃうと だからそこら辺で
そのそのミャンマーではミャンマーで美しく唱えられる単語を選んだりとか
もう随分いい加減好き勝手になってるみたいです
しかし 本心の意味からは脱線しません
だから実際のところ 私
個人的な意見を言うと
みんな慈悲の瞑想しています
これは慈か悲か喜か捨かどちらか分かってないんではないかなと
それでブッダごさまさんもそこは区別できなくて
実際にもう書いてないんですね
これ彼の仕事なんですけど
ちゃんと注釈するのは
我々は彼の注釈書から学んでテーラワーダ仏教語らなくちゃいけないんです
これで見たら あら もうあまり説明してないんです
そこで慈悲喜捨になるためには
じゃあ日本語とスリランカ語
ミャンマー語って別にどうでも関係ないことだから
私はこの四つの行で考え出したんです
これは慈悲喜捨に合わせて
あの幸福であり 何でしたっけ
悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
願うことは叶えられますように
悟りに達しますように
智慧が現れますようにという
それでちゃんと慈悲喜捨に飛ぶはずなんです
まあはずだけ だから一般的にはスリランカもミャンマーもタイはあんまり情報ないんだからわかりませんだけど
あのメッターで始まるんです
メッタバーヴァナだと思って
言葉の中身は悲に行くかどちらに行くかあまりわからないんですね
だからアハンアヴェーロホミー
怒りがなくなくなりますようにと
アッベアパジェ何でしたっけ
怒りです  次は恨み  恨みの次は怒り
瞋恚がなくなります  だからヴェーロは賄賂
瞋恚ですね アッベアパジェですから
もっと強烈な怒りですから
恨みでしょうね うん 恨みがなくなりますようにとかね
だから怒りがない状態はメッターでしょうね
だから見方によって あの
この人々は恨みで怒りで苦しんでるんだから可哀想や
みんな怒りがなくなりますようにと言うとカルナになっちゃうし
それだったら嫉妬がなくなりますように
欲がなくなりますように
煩悩がなくなりますまで言わなくちゃあかんけど
そこまで言わないでしょうね
そこはそんなにあんまり
まあ実際実践することだから
かなりファジーですよ
あとはその慈悲喜捨のウペッカーの場合は
感覚で捉えると風空 風楽っていう風に
違う違う それは違います
全く違います そのウペッカーと慈悲喜捨のウペッカーはまるっきり違います
だからどう考えたっても
まあ私が言ってるまあいい加減なようなこと言ってると感じるかもしれませんだけど
これは徹底的に研究して調べて言ってるんです
全部一言一言 そこは飛べないと思います
ブッダゴーサムもやってないところやってるんです
例えば私はシャーはウペッカーは全ての生命は平等であると見なさいと言ってるでしょうに
これ知恵はすごく優れてないと見えませんよ
で シャーになってくると
悲も喜ももう慈も悲も喜ももうなりたい
そんなところじゃないんです
かなり高いところで生命という風に見るだけで
それがアビダンマとかね
心理学的に見たっても
そういうことになります
なぜならば 瞑想はサマーディに達するところまで持っていかなくちゃいけないんです
そこまで計算して私は言ってるんです
で 我々仏教徒たちがもう毎日のこと子供頃からやってることだから
あんまり真剣じゃなくて
ただ単にやってるんですよ
それで真剣じゃなくたっても
日本の方々よりは慈悲はもうついてます
当たり前のこととして
生命に奉仕するのはこんなの言う必要ないだろうと
何がこれという慈悲なんです
もう全くもう当たり前になってます
もう当たり前になってるんだからって
じゃあ慈悲のサマーディに達しているかというと
そんなの分かりません
誰もそこまではやらないんですね
いわゆる実践のレベルでもう人に人を助けるのは当たり前やと
いうことは ミャンマーなんかに行ったら
外国人やヨーロッパ人からびっくりするでしょう
ミャンマー人っていうのは麻酔人ですけど
何のことなく助けてあげたりするんですよ
何人かね 有名な国際ジャーナリストの女性の言ってね
ミャンマーで一番厳しい時
女の人が自分の仕事も全部辞めて一緒にずっと行ったんですね
紹介しながら ジャーナリストは私はヨーロッパ人で白人だからね
まあこういう人々はね
まあお金いくら払えばいいでしょうと
どうせ自分たちは金持ち
お金たくさんあるんだからね
だからガイドとしてね
まあいいんじゃないかということで
ずいぶんわがままで あれやれこれやれ
あちらに行きたいんだから早く来てとかね
まあこの人もはいはい
わかりました はい わかりましたと
ずっと本人に必要なデータ全部取れるようにしてあげて
で 本人国へ帰らなくちゃいけないんですね
そしたらずっとあんたのおかげでね
ガイドでよく仕事できましたからね
あんたいくらですかと
いくらでもいいんだから言ってください
そしたらいい お金いりませんよと
それでこのジャーナリストの理解できない
なんだこれはと 最初からお金いりませんだから助けるぞと言ったら
もうちょっと怪しいでしょ
それも見せない 見せなかったとね
ちょっと金目当てのような感じで
それだったら誰でもね
言語喋れませんし ガイド雇うの当たり前だからね
英語を喋れる人だからね
それもなくちゃんと助けてあげて
国出国するところに お金いりませんよと
ただこれヨーロッパ志向だから
それでは困りますよと
なんとかあげなくちゃあかんと言ったら
この彼女が自分が折りたたみ傘持っていたんだそうですね
もし何て言いますか できればこの傘くれませんかと
それだったら それであんたが必要だったらいいですよと
いわゆる捨てることできる？できると思うならば
折りたたみの傘くれと
本人にとってはゴミと同じものでね
いくらでもあることでね
だからもう傘をあげたと
それすごくまた感謝されちゃったんだと
折りたたみ傘だけで 1週間ガイドしたと
だからそこで彼女がどれほど影響を受けたかというと
自分が研究するためにミャンマーに行ったレポートを書いた動機はそれよりはミャンマーのこの人の性格
それに驚いちゃって それですごい立派な
すごい感動的な記事を書って書いてあったんです
だから私たちは仏教徒だから
まあ別に珍しくても何ともなくわかるんですよ
彼女の行為は 彼女の立場から見れば
まあこの人は仕事に来たっても
もう何もできんでしょ
困ってるんだと 困ってる人を助けるのはこんなのは言う必要ないんですね
毎日日夜三時のことやって
日夜三時じゃなくても
じゃあ当たり前のことやと
だから昨日も言ったでしょ
当たり前の世界 いいよと
自分にはちょっと仕事休んだっていいっていうことでね
それぐらい自分にちょっと苦しいことあったって
それはいいことだからね
だからそっと困ってる人を助けてるだけ
困ってる人助けてまたご褒美もらうって
これとんでもない話なんです
だから最初からこの人から金取るという気持ちはないという
だからヨーロッパ人にとってはこのこんな厳しい軍事政権の中で
で これわからないんです
この人々のこの性格とかね
まあまあみんなどうかわかりませんだけど
やっぱりそれは慈悲喜捨なんですよ
慈悲喜捨の その場合はもう悲を実践した
二人とも女同士で また友達みたいな感じで
それでまた仲良しするということもあるし
それで最終的にあんた私協力して助かったんですかと
大いにだったら結構ですと
それで終わり じゃああんたの場合全然役に立たなかったと言ったら
それは困りますよということですよ
助かった よかったよかったと
自分の人生は無駄ではなかったと
当たり前のことだと だからこれ何でも当たり前で見る世界なんですよ
他の人々だったら あれ
何だこれという風に 商売世界でね
何でも売ったり買ったりする西洋文化でしょ
そのとこで物のことを考える
仏教の世界はもう随分思考が違います
そういうことだから 慈悲の瞑想を通してどうするのかと誰か聞いたっても
もうごちゃなんですよ
結局は だから仏教徒の立場から見れば
もう勝手にやりなさいよと
そんな慈悲で 慈であっても悲であっても喜であっても捨であってもね
あんた勝手にやりなさいと
できることは そういうふうなところをすっごくリラックスしてます
だからこの一応パーリ語にしてね
あれも経典じゃないんですよ
アハン・アウィローホミという文章は
どこかで書いたものでしょう
だからミャンマーバージョンで長い慈悲の瞑想の一つありましてね
それはスリランカでもテキストに入ったりしてね
まあだからいい文章できて
スリランカでいい文章ができたら
ミャンマーでも使うし
タイでも使うし ミャンマーでいい文章できちゃうと
スリランカでもどこでも使うって
そういうところでも随分ごちゃなんです
全然もう文化ということさえも考えないんですよ
だからあの北の方に住んでいる人々に怒りがない
南の方に住んでいる人々に怒りがないようにとかね
四方八方に分けたら 延々と文章を伸ばすんです
神々ももう動物たちも
天国に地獄にいる人々になんの怒りがないようなようにとかね
もうだからそちらで狙いは怒りがありませんようにという一言葉にかけて
生命の数を増やしていくんです
それが本格的な慈悲の瞑想のやり方なんです
それで無量ということになるんです
だから 慈か悲か喜か捨かということはあんまり気にしないんです
だからしっかりしてますよ
だから心育ててる場合は心臓を一つ育ててるんであって
慈悲喜捨は一緒の心に生まれません
だからとりあえず瞑想を始めると
それは慈になるのか 悲になるか
喜になるか 捨になるかと気にしないんです
一つに定めたら そこで心は進んでいくんです
心を進めるために 瞑想
慈悲の瞑想を進めるためには
生命の数を増やさなくちゃいけないんです
生命の数を増やすると
この気持ちも広げて強化していくんです
そういうことは一般人もみんな知ってます
普通 こちら日本の方のあの
あの 何でしたっけ あの人
アカスカさんというね
タイに長い住んでる人でね
昔は私のところにもあったけどね
で タイの女の人と結婚して
お金もないしね で キリスト教の関係でいて
いろいろボランティアとかやっていてね
そこから離れてまた今別のことをやってますけどね
自分のおくさんがお金もないのに
ちょこっと何かお金ちょっと入っちゃうと
すぐ何んとこどっかに寄付されてるんだと
お寺に必ず一応祈りしてるんだと
そしたらある日もうもう
その人に聞いたんだと
私に言うの 私もあの人に聞いた
あんたちょっとお金が入っちゃうと
本人も嫌じゃないんです
寄付することはね 本人もこちらで仏教を学んでいったんだから
なんとか寄付して色々お祈りしているんだと
あなた何をお祈りしてるんですかと聞いたら
本人もしかするともっと幸福になりますようにと
自分の家族がね 今お金がなく苦しんでるんだから
そういとく おそらく奥さんだから女の人とかお祈りするだろうと思っていたでしょうね
そしたらこの人 私は今この功徳をね
全ての生命にありますようにと祈っただけやと
で またわからなくなっちゃって
この何考えてるの？何かお坊さんに寄付して一切の生命が幸福になります
どういうお祈りでしょうかと
で 私はそこを聞いただけでニコッと笑って
私はもうものすごく通じるんですよ
彼女の気持ちは それでやっぱり仏教徒は仲間やと
じゃあパーリ語とか学んでればそんなのわかりますよ
結局は そういうところは他の人々には敵わないんですよ
ブッダにすっごく似てるところがね
だから表面的に何かだらしなく見えたっても
ものすごい人格者たちがいるんですよ
それこそすごい人格でしょう
他の国々ではもうなかなかそこまではって
あれってまたインチキで何ともなく
ものすごく正直というところ
だから聞いてこっちで笑うとこじゃないんですよ
こう話を聞いた瞬間に
あ 私たちももっと真面目になっちゃって気分にさせるんだからね
あ やっぱりそうか もっと頑張らないと
このだらしない生き方はダメやと自分たちにも戒めとしてその言葉来るんですよ
では彼女へそのことを先生言ってないんです
一回自分の寺にも行きましたけどね
で 日本の方々みんな言っても全部リーダー彼女なんです
だからその人格っていうのはブッダの世界から得られる真の清さなんです
でお寺で祭りやったんだから
アカサさんも じゃあ今度自分も行くんだと
たくさんグループで行きましたけど
ミニさんもその時行きましたし
でも 日本の人々は結構力強く
結局あの人入っちゃうと
もうその人言う通りで
何の力かと 別に先生お金力も何もない
苦労して航空券買っただけで
だからすごい力ですよ
慈悲の力っていうのは
私もいちいち人にものを言うんだけど
仏教徒には何も言いませんね
すぐ下がります これやりたい
あれやりたい あれやりたい
はいはい どうぞどうぞ
これはもう上で飛ばして何か言うことはもう不可能です
ブッダの世界の人々だからね
[背景音楽]だからこの慈悲の瞑想の場合はね
まあ慈悲喜捨にはっきり区別したければ
日本語の四行で考えるしかないんです
ブッダゴーサ長老の本を見たっても
じゃあ捨のウペッカーの瞑想どうするのかというふうに全然ないんです
どちらかというと 慈と喜が
慈と悲がなんか混ざってるような感じなんで
言葉では はっきり言えばなんかみんな何でしたっけ？ヒーロー瞑想してるみたい
おっしゃった通りに 苦しみがなくなりますようにと
わかりました うん うん
すいません 最近自分を観察してわかったことがあるんですけど
私の心の中に相当ろくでもないものが入っています
これにどう対処していいのかわからないで悩んでる面があるんですが
どうすればいいでしょうか
なるほど 問題はね 私は発見していないんですよ
あなたの心の中にあるこのろくでもないものは
発見した人の仕事です
それは あなたの家でネズミがいると発見したら
ネズミ退治するのはあなたの仕事であって
ゴキブリがいると発見したら
ゴキブリ退治とネズミ退治のやり方違いますよ
別に私に聞かなくてもいいんです
だから自分が発見するものは自分で
じゃあこう対処すればいいかということは考えた方がいいと思います
これは出せる答えじゃなくて
自分独立するための 今そういう道しかないんです
わかりました 頑張ってみます
そんな笑わないでください
なんですか 私はこれでも
青年部のことで 青年部のことでちょっとあるんですけれど
パティパタにもちょろっと書いたんですけれど
青年部はあの集まる場があれば定着するんじゃないかという考えからなってるんですけど
今日の説法を聞いて その考えが何か不安になってきました
なんで？ なんというか
その弱いから集まるとか
そのうつむくとかっていう風なニュアンスと
やっぱり集まっていかなきゃならないんじゃないかって考えてる自分があるだなと
何かこう  だから人間っていうのはどうしても学ぶ世界でしょうに
だから だからはっきり説明したんですよ
俗世間の集まりと仏教の集まりのあるところで違うところありますよと
我々はお互い学ぶために集まるんですよ
俗世間の集まりっていうのは
お互いに依存するために
依存してお互いに噛みついて力強くなりたいんです
こちらはお互いで学んで成長していきたいというね
青年部そのものがあの俗世間的な雰囲気で
こう噛みつき合うような感じで
こんなに経ってしまったらまずいかなと思ってる面があるんですけれど
だからそうならないように
まあみんなお互いみんな平等であると
お互いだから親分じゃなくて
だからそこはポイントですよ
親分は設定してない このサンガは一番古い組織でしょ
世界で 親分がいないんだからね
サンガの中で でもしっかりやってますよ
タイだけですね サンガラージャという僧王という人がいるのは
それでもあまり相手にしないんです
例えば自分の国でも日本にも来たでしょ
観衆とかね 組織的な 本当は中身にお互い冗談言ったりからかったりとかね
政治的には偉いということにするだけで
随分冗談言ったり 我々からかったりとか
私たちもいろいろ言い返したりとかね
本当は弱者のグループの親分じゃないんです
だからこのリーダーがというか
親分ない世界です 平等
先生はまた親分とはまた違う
私は一度も親分にはなったことはないです
さっきのダンマ話で悪行為をする人とあとカリスマ性を持った人って 2つに分けられたんですけど
それ  悪行為する人と悪行為するカリスマの人
はいはい 例えばですね
ものすごく悪さをした人がいるとします
だけどそれはその しても自分はあまり影響は受けないと
で かたや あの さほど悪さはしないんだけど
その自分にとってすごく影響力があるっていう場合に
その後者の方を  危ないです
危ないと そういう意味ですか
わかりました  すいません
はい あの観念信義が間違っているかいう最近のことじゃない
昔の方からの質問なんですけど
玄侑さんとの対談の方でですね
だからあの ちょっと質問というか
ほとんど確認みたいな質問なんですが
玄侑さんがコインを投げた時に
落ちた時にチャリンという音がする
その それはもう自分の認識の中に入っているので
投げる前からチャリンという音がするので
それがすなわち色で落ちたところが空であるとかいう説明を長老にされて
長老はそれの説明は正しいですか？という玄侑さんのお言葉に対して
いろんな説明がありますから
何とも言えませんというのが答えだったんですが
それはちょっとまあ ああいう本になってるからそういうふうに答えられているのであって
本当はやっぱり間違ってるいうふうに思った方がいいかという
それは確認の一つなんですよね
要はあのチャリンという音を頭の中で落ちる前に認識したのは色即是空で
実際に落ちた時は受想
受即是空であるというふうに
まあ簡単に言えば言空というふうに解釈するんじゃないかなと
そういうふうに思うんですが
それとその後で玄侑さんが色即是空の反対である是色空即是空まるというふうに言われてるんですが
あれは単純に空即是色という言葉もあるという
単なるほんの誤植でいう風に解釈でよろしいのでしょうか
だからそちらはね 玄侑さん
まだまだね まあどうでもいいんですけど
いい人ですけど 大丈夫
全体的にはもう分かってないことだから
まとめて捨てちゃえばどうですかね
色受想行識は何だと学んでないんですよ
だからこの観念的な言葉に引っかかって説明しようとするんだから
最初からもう失敗なんですよ
それがキリスト教で初めは神がありきというところが設定しておいて苦労していることと同じなんですよ
神を証明してやるぞと
余計なことを初めはあんなこと
くだらんこと証明もなく考えたあなた間違いでしょうと
順番があべこべですと私は言いたいんですよ
調べて調べたところで神が発見したならば正しい順番なのに
まず初めは神がありき
あら 神がいることを証明しなくちゃいけない
それから考えて どういうこと話ですかね
だから大丈夫な空も同じこと
初めは空でありきと決めつけちゃって
それからごちゃごちゃごちゃ言うんだから
これ思考自体あべこべなんですね
そういう考えは成り立たないんですよ
だから実際信仰する人の面と面に向かってね
批判はできませんだからね
どうせ対話だから お互い様五分五分でいかなくちゃいけないんですよ
対話したっても いろいろなんとなく暗黙の決まりありますからね
わかりました だから前提
前提みたいなちょっと間違ってるから
それ以上細かいことで反論しても仕方がない
仕方がないんですよ  そういうふうに理解して
すいません あの 修行者の人に
失礼なことなんですか？修行者の人に失礼な行為って何ですか？ うーん
[笑い]どう答えればいいんですかね
裏があるみたいで あなたの質問にね
自分はお坊さんとかに接するときにお坊さんとかと接するときに
やっぱあの自分はこっち側の人間なんで
あの 感覚 感覚っていうのかなんか考え方が違うのかなと思って
こっちの俗世間の方では
あの なんとなく相手に失礼な行為を与えないで
自分もあの 自分のことをやるみたいなのがなんとなくわかるんですけど
なんかお坊さんとかにはなんかそれはあんまりよくわかんないから
とりあえずあの自分のことを考えるだけでいいのかなとか思っちゃうんですけど
まあそんなにあの まあ普通
自然に付けばいいんですよ
別に気にすることはないと思います
わかりました はい 今日悪い人というか
悪い友という話が出たと思うんですけど
それはあの愚か者という言葉
言葉というか 同じと考えてよろしいんでしょうか
似ています 愚か者が悪いことするんだから
理性の悪い人 悪いことしないでしょう
うん この場合はこの今日どちらに焦点を合わせるかというと
この悪い悪いことに焦点を合わせるんですね
わかりました ありがとうございます
はい あの先生 今日の説法ですが
生まれ変わったらまた一から勉強し直しだっていうお話です
ずっと自分をしつけしつけし続けなきゃいかんっていう風におっしゃいますけど
そういうことがわかっていながら
例えばブッダになるために頑張るんだっていう人は
あんたそういう質問するだろうと最初から思っていたんです
[笑い]面白くない あいつはポイントを持ってくると
石原さん これ恐らく必ず持ってくるんだと
一応そういう質問するだろうとわかるものは
説法している間で分析したりするんですけど
これがややこしいんだから取り扱いしないとしたんです
まあ何かは残りますよ
これは我々性格とか習性とかいろいろ言ってることですからね
まあそれですよ だって犬見てもみんな同じじゃないしね
私はよく犬と子供っていうのをよく観察する
私の頭の中では犬と子供って同じなんです
同じくするんです 子供ちっちゃい子とやってることを見たら
犬やってること同じじゃないか
です だから昔は本当にすごいちっちゃな子供かわいいかわいいと見ます
お母さんも喜んだりする
私の頭の中で子犬扱いしててわからない
子犬だと思って遊んでるんですね
なんておしっこしたいとか
おしっこするわ もうもうめちゃくちゃですからね
しかしよく見ると どんな子供も同じパターンでやってますね
同じこと  俺に だから皆様には残念ながらね
子供がいたっても一人の子供しか見ることできないんだから
経験ないと思います 私はたくさん子供たち見ているんだから
年だけ知ったらもう全部深全部知ってるんです
どうしゃべればいいか
何すればいいか 好き嫌いは何やとかね
全部わかってワンパターンだからね
で そこであ 子供ならこの基本的にこのプログラムでいくぞというね
わかっているのに それから差が見えてくるんですね
それが過去から持ってくるものなんですね
で それまた変えられますからね
だから性格とか何とかというものでしょうね
いろいろ能力とかね まあ何である人とかね
早く勉強するんで なんである人はね
ずっと苦労しなくちゃいけないかとかね
そういうふうには個人個人の差があります
ブッダになる資格っていうのは一生一つの人生ではもう間に合わないんです
だから長い間修行してして資格を取って取って取って取っていくんです
形にならない ある特定な能力っていうのは心にはあるんですね
だから自分はね 自己観察できれば
自分のいいところを見て
そこは伸ばして伸ばして
悪いところはぶつんと消すということをしなくちゃいけないんですよ
この人はやろうとして
あんたやろうとしてないでしょうにね
生徒か師匠と いつでもそれでしょう
だからその時点でこちら上で
あんたはまだ上じゃないんです
だから誰にでもいいところもあって
悪いところもいろいろあったりして
そこは自己観察して いいところ伸ばそうとかね
悪いところはなんとかしてぶつけてやるぞっていう努力が必要なんです
修行ってのはそういうことで
お釈迦様はずっと輪廻転生して修行したっていうことは
パーリ密教学者ってそういうことなんです
何か１項目悪いところ潰す
何か１項目いいとこを伸ばすという
ジャータカ物語そういうことなんです
そこで人格を完成する
それはもう無数の輪廻転生して修行しないと
もう時間的に間に合わないんですよ
だってブッダになるなるものは
まず言語的に人に喋ることにすごい世界人類一でなければいけませんよ
大変な危険な作業だから
お釈迦様おっしゃった一言は
今でも誰かがこれちょっと言葉間違っているよと言われたら最悪ですよ
言葉の使い方ちょっとおかしいじゃないかとか言えないんだから
今日の偈でも見てください
悪人と付き合うなよと
終わってないでしょうに
悪人とプリサーデマと付き合うなよと
ちゃんと 2つに分けてますよ
この完璧性っていうのは一生で得るものじゃないんですよ
それからこのカリスマ性がないと
もうどんなものでも意味がないんですよ
だからもう生命一カリスマ性を持たなくちゃいけないんですよ
ブッダは 喋る能力 それまた生命一にならなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからブッダは稀に生まれるというね
その修行はすごい長い時間かかると
恵まれている 徳といえば世界一でなきゃ成り立たないんですよ
あんた家は貧しかったんだから
もうすぐ修行して里建てて言い張ってるでしょとか言いますからね
それもダメなんです あるいは見ただけで体形がもうもうちょっと不細工だったらうまくいかないんですよ
完璧で何でもかんでも完璧なんです
だからブッダが現れたら
もう理性ある人はそのチャンスは逃さないんです
だから だからすごい もう何百万
何百何百万年とかありますからね
で 修行して いろいろそういったわけ
我々も同じでしょう いろいろ各性の癖持ってますからね
で その中でいいところを伸ばしたり
悪いところは何か 1項目でも潰しちゃえばね
それは精進という定義あるでしょうね
悪をなくすこと 善をなすことに精進する
明確にぴったし全部定義定義していますよ
それでも人生はゼロから始めなくちゃいけないんで
お釈迦様もゼロから始めたんですよ
あのバラモン人から 先生から学んだりして
武士道 だから武士でしょう
一応王家だから だからちゃんと戦争の訓練も受けたりして
馬に乗ることやら 走ることやら
弓 弓のそのなんとか術やらね
全部やってます それ何か欠けてると
もうブッダとして堂々と語れませんよ
王様たちはペコペコとしながらね
お釈迦様にアドバイス受けませんよ
どう見たっても叶わないんだからね
コーサラ王様同じ年なのに
同じ年なのに もう誰にも叶わないんだと
王子としては だって体見たってコーサラ様お腹太ってデブで
もう動かない走れないわ
それでもうもう軍人務まりますかと
軍人なんて言います？その場合は
最高司令官？将軍なの？務まりますかと
これでお釈迦様見たってしっかりした体で細くて
そこまで気をつけるんです
だからどう調べたっても
一言葉言いたいところはブッダの中で見つかりっこはないんだから
人間だから何かあるはずっていうことはありますよ
ないんです あるっていうところもはっきりくっきりと記録しているんです
お釈迦様にあって いろいろ病気とかね
だからそれこういうこういうところありますよと
腰のね 腰の腰が痛みがあったりとかね
で 胃が悪くてね そういうところもちゃんと隠してないんです
まあとにかく まあこれは誰にでも同じことですからね
まあ一応なんとかは残ってます
それはある方向に行けば専門的に育ちますけど
輪廻転生する人はある方向は決めてないでしょ？ただ生きて死ぬだけでしょうに
だから修行ということにならないんです
パーラミターというのは
ある一定ある一つ方向性決めて輪廻転生するんです
方向性決めたんだから成長になるんです
方向性決めてないと  それは一般の人もそうなんですか？一般の人は
一般の人でも方向性決めれば輪廻
それ続けますよ  一応そういうふうな意識でやった方がいいってことですか
うん パラーミタを進むんだっていう意識で
たとえ悟れなくても パラーミタを進むんだという意識でやった方がいい
悟らなくてもではなくてね
とにかくもう悟りまでやるぞというと
今世で時間間に合わなかったら
まあ次はチャンスが得られます
悟るまでやるぞと言ったっても
人格的なものすごい身近な未熟なとこいろいろ見つかっちゃうと
それを順番に順番にまあ直すチャンスが得られます
やっぱり方向性決めることがアディッターナというし
まあね パーミッターとも言うんですね
だからソメイダって菩薩の時代でブッダになるぞと決める
その方向を決めて輪廻転生する
もうすぐに輪廻転生するんですけど
方向は決めてます だからゼロから始まるのに
そちらとケッ違うことになっちゃうんです
ただ森の中で彷徨うか
何か集着点決めて歩むかということで
普通の人々はもうただ彷徨うだけで
森の中で 菩薩はあそこまでとにかく行くぞと言って
森をずっともう通して行くんです
見ればみんな森の中であちこち歩いてるだけなんですね
見てみれば でも彷徨ってる人もなんかどこ進んでるでしょ
進んではいるんですけど
彷徨ってるんだから じゃあこちら左に右にしよう
左に まあいいわ こちらにしようと決まるでしょうね
方向性決めて いえ こちらは左に行っちゃうと
日の陽がこちらで 西こちらであれであれって
やっぱり行きづらいんだけど
ここら辺登っていこうというふうに思っちゃうんです
彷徨っている人はここら辺がもう坂道ですから
ここら辺なんか水の音も聞けるんだぞと
いや あちら行こうよ 今晩はそちらに泊まろうとかね
方向性ある人はそうかもしれません
だが 私はあちらで行くんだから
この険しい崖はやっぱり登って向こう側に行くぞと
そこやるのと探すくんですよ
だからパーラミタの場合はその方向性決めることなんですね
アディッターナというね
誓願というね だから輪廻転生する時でも似ている生命になると
かなり前のことを思い出したりする
例えば人間が死んでまた人間に生まれちゃうと
すごい簡単ですよ もう過去を思い出したり
その能力を蘇らせたりすることは
前スリランカで子供がいてね
生まれてもう4歳5歳になってしゃべりだしちゃうと
もう経典を覚えていて
ペラペラペラペラ経典開けたりする
どこで覚えた誰も知らない
それがイントネーションの素晴らしさ
もう感動するね 聞いちゃうと
それで人間でしたから
この思いを蘇らしちゃって
それで過去で学んだところは何のことなく覚えていて
それでその子供の声聞いて
私も自分も止まるとこ
やっぱり俺が違ったな
あちらで止まるこの子供の方が正しいと
私は文字を数えて で 訪問で数えて止まるとこあるんですけど
時々あの子も難しい経典とかあげたりするテープありましたからね
子供には言えない難しい因果法則の経典とかね
あれ この子はこちらで止めて次こっちに持っていくんだと
で 子供には生きが短いんだからね
いろんなところに泊まりますけど
それはそんなに気にしませんよ
やっぱり子供だって分かりますけど
わざといろんなところでカチッと止めて
また始まる あ これが正しいんだと自分さえ学んだんだから
その時も私はもうその子初めて聞く三十五音取っていたんですけど
だから三十五歳になっている人にもやっぱり学ぶものあると
このちっちゃな子供の声聞いて
そこはもうなぜかというと
やっぱりもう輪廻転生する時は
そういう似ているところで回転すると思い出すことはできます
我々が でもその解脱の方に行くためには
人間から人間に生まれ変わるのが難しいとすると
その下の次元に落ちちゃうとは
もうとても都合なんか離れちゃうっていうと
方向性決めたらそんな心配することはないんです
だって菩薩物語を見ると
もう犬に犬になったことない
牛にもなるし ライオンにもなるしね
全然邪魔になったことはないんです
だから実際犬にライオンになったかどうかはわかりませんだけど
物語ですから 言いたいのは
まあそこはいろいろ行儀があっても心配することはないんだと
やることやるんだよと
例えばライオンで菩薩が生まれちゃっても
やることはやるんです
鹿で生まれちゃってもやることはやるんです
そのユニットのユニットで与えられた仕事をするんです
だから方向性を決めたら
そのその場合で与えられた仕事を完了して亡くなるんです
それ終わったら はい 次の宿題と次の生まれで
そこはまあ次の宿題やればいいんです
まあそれでもそのその生命に形取ったところで
学ぶものをまたゼロから学ばなくちゃいけないということは当然ですよ
例えばベートーヴェンというのは加工性で癖があってすごいことを作ったかもしれませんだけど
しかし 彼が音楽を最初から学んだんです
学ぶこともなくできるわけないでしょ
学んだんだけど 他の人とはちょっと差があるんですね
だから現代でもね 天才みたいな能力の天才能力ある人もいるでしょう
でもみんな小学校から始まりますよ
結局は 問題は小学生で二人で子供友達始まりますけど
一年終わるとこの人は中学の学びも終わってるだけの話
でもゼロから学ばなくちゃいけないんです
それでも はい それで話はそこは終わり
では 他の質問なければ
はい どうぞ  シンハラ経の最後にサンガがっていうのが出てきまして
その中にサマーニャッタサーっていうのが出てくるんですが
それはどういうことを言っているのでしょうか
それは他の人々と同じ気持ちで
自分も他人も同じだと思いなさいってことでしょう
平等ということ  平等でということですね
ではあの まだはい  今日の七十八番目のこの偈は
あのまあ命令形になってるんじゃ命令形っていうか
インストラクションみたいになってて
具体的にこれを実践しようと読んだ人
例えば私が読んで思う場合ですね
まず自分はどうかと考えると
自分の心が卑しいか卑しくないかというと
まあ率直に言って卑しい方だろうと
自分はいい人間か悪い人間かと自問自答すると
どちらかといえば犯罪者ではないけども
悪の方だろうと こういうふうな前提でこれを実践しようとする場合ですね
いい友たちを探すとか
本当にやりたい人 与えたい人を具体的にどう探せたらいいんだろうと思ってしまうんですが
その長老の話を聞いていると
結局究極のところは その清き友とか尊敬に値する人というのはブッダの教え
だから自分がこの七十八の戒を実践しようと思った場合ですね
字面だけ見ると 誰か友達を探せと書いてはあるけれども
やはりその仏教というか
ブッダの教えを自分で勉強して実践して
自分で行くしかないという風に解釈
解釈というか 自分で行きなさいということを教えているんですよね
まあこれしかないという言葉はどうかわかりませんだけど
自分で学ぶことも一つの方法なんです
以前 長老の法話の中でアングリバーラとかいう悪人がおってですね
パーリ仏典の中に通ったけど
あれはブッダの方から近づいていったわけですね
近づいたというか 捨てに行ったわけですけども
要するに 大部分の人は自分は貧しい心がいやしくないとか
自分は汚い人間だとは思ってなくて
何かこう どちらかと言えば悪の方だと心が卑しいと思っている人間が大部分ですけども
その場合は かといって遠くというものは
それはそれで罪だと思うんですけど
なるべく仏を組まないでいくとすれば
やはりその清き友とか尊敬に値する人の究極はいろいろいらっしゃるだろうけれども
結局やっぱりそのブッダの教えとしましょうか
ブッダそのものになるから
だからそこを問題は具体的に頭
首 カソで稼げる必要ないと私は初めから言ったでしょうに
友達は必ず作らなくちゃいけないということはないんだよと
もう必ずしも友達いなくてはいけないということはないと私は言っておいたんだから
だから首カスで稼げるんじゃないんです
ポイントは 学ぶことなんです
ポイントは 学ぶためにどうすればいいかと
学ぶためにはブッテン学べば人格が変わりますよというならば
それで結構ですよ ブッテン読んだっても
そちらに裏にいるのはお釈迦様だから
お釈迦様と付き合っていることでしょうに
だから私には人間の友達がいないんだから
お釈迦様友達にするそうと言うと
もうブッテンしかないでしょうに
それだったらお釈迦様に恥じないようにということをしなくちゃいけないんです
私にも友達がいないんだけど
私はいつでもやっぱりお釈迦様にだけは怒ら怒鳴らないようにするぞというぐらいだけは気をつけますよ
いろいろいい加減なことをやりますけど
その時こういう言い訳で逃れますよとかね
いう風に いつでも自分を監視
観測 監督している存在としてのお釈迦様を設定してあるんです
だからあまり人間言うことはそんなに
聞かなくなっちゃうんですね
他の人はすごい頑固で感じるかもしれませんだけど
自分は頑固じゃなくてすごい謙虚でいますよ
謙虚なんですけど やっぱりアドバイスをする場合はブッダにするんです
どうしようか困ったなという
すぐもうこうしなさいということがちゃんと来るんだからね
それには十分仏教を勉強してるんだから
問題なくもう順次に来るんです
答えは だから最高たる戦友がブッダであるんで
それはもう紛れもない事実なんです
一旦設定してみれば もうなんのことない
二十四時間ちゃんとアドバイスあるんですよ
ありがとうございます
では祝福のお経をあげます
ナモタッセ・ナガヴァト・アラハト・サマー・サンビッドタッセ
イティピソ・ワラワ・アラハン・サマー・サンビッドヨ・ヴィッキャ・チャラナ・サンパンノ・サガト・ローカ・ヴィドゥ・アナッタ・ロー・プリサ・ダンマ・サラーテ
ィ・サッサーティ・ウィラマヌッサーナ・ブッド・ワラワーティ・スワカト・ナガヴァタ・ダンモ・サンビッティコ・アカーリコ・ヘディ・タッシコ・ウパーリコ・パッチ
ャッタン・ヘディ・ダッボ・インデーヒ・スプラティパンノ・バガヴァト・サーラカサンゴー・スプラティパンノ・バガヴァト・サーラカサンゴー・ナリ・スプラティ
パンノ・バガヴァト・サーラカサンゴー・サーミーチ・スプラティパンノ・バガヴァト・サーラカサンゴー・ヤティ・ナンチャッターニ・プリサ・イカーニ・アッタ・
プリサ・プッガラー・レーサ・バガヴァト・サーラカサンゴー・アヴネイヨ・ウパー・アヴネイヨ
[集団]